[Musique]
la 10e édition de l'événement odyssea
réunion aura lieu les 4 et 5 novembre
2010 est dans la forêt de l'etang-salé
cette manifestation sportive et
solidaire a pour but de lutter contre le
cancer du sein à la réunion odyssea fête
ses 10 ans et pour nous c'est important
qu'on a ce chiffre un peu symbolique de
20000 personnes dit bill le samedi et le
dimanche et surtout le chiffre d'
objectif de 140 mille euros de dons ça
c'est primordial pour nous afin que la
fête soit belle l'association run
odyssea a décidé cette année d'élargir
et de diversifier le programme mais
aussi de proposer de nouveaux parcours
de la manifestation les dettes sur le
samedi après midi et dimanche matin va
ouvrir dès le samedi matin avec une
course de la diversité qui sera ouvert à
toutes les personnes qui le souhaiteront
mais notamment aux personnes
à mobilité réduite ensuite on aura une
zone bas le samedi matin qui est quelque
chose de nouveau qui sera ouvert à 500
personnes et l'autre nouveauté c'est le
10 km sur route qui devient 10 km mixte
avec de la route d'abord et ensuite on
passe dans la forêt l'organisation de la
course odyssea dépend essentiellement de
l'aide financière des nombreux
partenaires publics et privés
c'est tout naturellement que le
département a souhaité comme chaque
année faire partie de l'aventuré
département étant acteurs de la santé
publique
le département se doit je dis rien
d'être aux côtés de toutes ses actions
et notamment dans le cadre de deux de
ses dix ans odyssea mais dans le cadre
de l'action dit c'est à tous les ans
d'accompagner et d'apporter sa pierre à
l'édifice que les inscriptions sont
ouvertes depuis le 4 juillet elle
s'effectue en ligne dans la limite des
20 milles places disponibles sur
l'ensemble des épreuves jusqu'au 6
octobre
[Musique]